some scary incidents in the air two
alarming incidents affecting air travel
all across the U.S this week the new
cell phone video showing a passenger who
tried to open an emergency exit while
the plane was in flight this is during a
cross-country Journey Sunday and then he
allegedly attacked a flight attendant he
was arrested after the plane landed at
Boston's Logan airport and that airport
is also where two planes bumped into
each other on the tarmac yesterday hard
to call it a fender bender when you're
talking about planes Lily Luciano has
these stories
I'm taking over this plane cell phone
video captured the frightening moments
aboard a flight from Los Angeles to
Boston Sunday officials say Francisco
Torres threatened other passengers and
crew members he said he wanted to jump
out of the plane and attempted to open a
cabin door they say he then tried to
stab a flight attendant in the neck with
a broken metal spoon before other
passengers and crew took him down
however not going quietly he's just
laying there with six able bodies on top
of them the flight attendant was not
seriously injured Torres is under arrest
and could face life in prison and
yesterday two United planes clipped
their wings while on the tarmac at
Boston Logan investigators say it
happened when one United Plane being
towed made contact with another that was
parked at the neighboring gate no one
was injured me meanwhile a close call
from last month in Florida is now under
investigation the NTSB says an American
Airlines 737 cleared for landing at
Sarasota Bradenton International Airport
was forced to initiate a go-around when
an Air Canada jet was cleared for
takeoff on the same Runway
why does it feel like flying these days
is less safe I really want to emphasize
that flying on a commercial airline in
the United States is extremely safe but
the NTSB and the FAA are working hard to
understand these events to keep them
from happening for CBS mornings I'm
Lilia Luciano